a kaput collusion everybody should live
by themselves because you don't need
anybody else to make yourself happy
hey everyone my name is Matt Bella Sian
this is whine about it a weekly video
series where I get drunk at my desk and
complain about stuff on this week's
episode the worst types of roommates
let's drink alright first of all there's
always that one roommate who never takes
out the garbage using this is some kind
of game this is some kind of garbage
game where if you pile your Tower of
shame tall enough the little little
garbage fairy will come and take off all
your garbage wait little garbage fairy
just come and gobble up all your garbage
guess what the garbage fairy it's me
it's me who's the garbage fairy I take
out all the garbage all this time that's
why I use your toothbrush scrub the
toilet and I get it there deep another
so that roommate they're all winners
she's always in there with her boyfriend
they're just bumping uglies way too loud
all the time Congrats on all the sex
you're having I'm so happy for you but 5
to hear you shouting the lyrics to Ave
Maria while you're in there stirring
your potato salad well I'm trying to
watch The Real Housewives I'm gonna spit
in your box the Special K with red
berries again I'm gonna spit right in it
you know that sound that it makes me
stir up a cold potato salad that's the
sound it makes like to whet slugs
there's ramen then there's that one
roommate who thinks okay to eat my food
right out of the fridge like I'm not
even gonna notice if you think for a
second that I don't count every stick of
the sweet potato fries that are in the
fridge you're out of here they have mine
so just like my children food it's like
my babies do you think it's okay to just
come to my fridge and eat my babies eat
up all my little babies every time
someone eats my food I reserve the right
to punch him right in the kidneys
the Constitution let it out that's why
our family father said they didn't even
have two kidneys then they all all of
them only had one Benjamin Franklin one
kidney that's why it was so important to
them then there's that one roommate who
just never does the dishes they just let
him pile up in a hole wet crusty mess oh
forgot that's what I say oh I just
forgot to do the dishes oh you just
forgot for three months straight well
that family of squirrels moved in under
that pot that you couldn't scrub for 20
seconds maybe I'll just forget not to
tell everybody about that thing I saw
you doing in the bathroom with the
bottle of mustard look I just didn't
forget that don't forget that everybody
another bow also why are there so many
damp pubes on your bar soap what are you
doing down there what are you doing to
yourself
show some respect I don't even know how
you use that soap to get clean
it looks like an angry Hedgehog it's
just in there growling back at me just
look at me right in the face
but it's too furry little eyes furrow
and it's pubie brow also roommates who
terrorize my netflix suggestions as they
go in there and they watch all their
shitty dump shows so garbage is what
they watch and I'm getting suggestions
for some crime watching go detective
mystery all because you watched 30
seconds of some [ __ ] on my Netflix
account
I don't want that I don't want that out
of my Netflix account also a roommate
who deletes a single second off of my
DVR my DVR is like a sandwich I picked
out all the meats all the cheese's all
the breads it's like you came in here
you just took big old peak right on it
you peed on my sandwich my DVR sandwich
that's why everyone shall live by
themselves
no we're remains okay okay okay all
right buddy thank you for watching this
week as always so you can find our
videos every week I whine about it
komm from my facebook page which is
facebook.com slash BuzzFeed man
everyone's always like now what do you
do at work when you're done nothing